[Music]
how many
in this room
hold digital
goods digital goods like an nft i own i
have video games that are digital right
it's not an mt but i have uh the whole
collection of main bus oh that's a
digital good really all out i have a 95
luna
oh i do have i do have some uh that's
not a good that's a bad yeah um
dude we're guys in demolition derby and
like our [ __ ] rv's all [ __ ] up
it's gonna make it spray and coolant
[Laughter]
so uh this this cat from texas he put he
put his life savings
into buying
digital property oh no in the metaverse
it's either oh no or just [ __ ]
on what's called the quorum coast which
is a piece of virtual land in the
entropia universe which is an online
virtual reality game what's the amount
he spent 18 g's
that's his whole life
yeah i thought that too oh [ __ ] one
would hope so yeah yeah hopefully he's
like 19. well that's two times more than
my life right now it is but you could
not die oh i'm kidding
it doesn't say 60 years
i mean i didn't have 18 g's at 19. what
does this property look like 18 g's in
it
[Laughter]
so he says he's been playing this he's
been playing entropia
so his name his name is uh is justin but
he he calls himself david joker in the
game [ __ ] nerd terrible dude it's not
a good name david
my real name is david
my last name
joker okay that's a [ __ ] okay steven
batman yeah i mean exactly what the [ __ ]
are you doing iceman green
well that has a ring that's a little bit
better well that's pretty crazy mr nikki
limo green that's pretty good it's
profitable
uh so so he's been playing this game for
20 years
along the way he cashed out five g's
from the game to help pay for college
and and now he is hoping to make a
return on this virtual land investment
in just four years time so he says he
gets a revenue based on everything that
a player finds out there if they go out
doing their mining i get three percent
tax revenue on that and that's how i get
my income okay so how that's not a
bubble
i'll never know
did he has he has he made more money
since then or is this a tragic story no
so he's he's saying he spends 60 a year
to keep his animals stocked on his land
but he currently pays no land taxes so i
think you get what you i think you get
where it's going
where does it go i don't know bart
straight to the dumpster
it's so [ __ ] confusing because i
honestly am such a hater of nfts
actually that i i wait so is this a
metaverse or nft it sounds like a video
game so this game i think has been
upgraded over the years and it is
currently like an unreal engine like
level game where you can play it right
now you can download the game right now
it's called entropia universe
and like it's got cool graphics and
stuff but like yeah it's a it's a game
that he's in and virtual land and so
people could like
mine [ __ ] on his land if they do
anything on his land he gets attacked
it's a tax okay
so he's making passive income on land
is he is he up or down
well he's technically up if he cashed
five grand out to pay for college but it
doesn't say that it just he's just
talking about like what he's what his
plan is for like four years because he's
wanting to cash out in four years so he
doesn't really care about like the
interim that's like right now like
honestly with crypto for me personally
it's like
i don't give a [ __ ] about right now i'm
about building positions again for the
run which is coming later the trend is
your friend so you have to wait for the
trend to come back your way yeah the
ball is going to come you can't force it
you can't do anything about it you have
to like try to pick your play
like call your shot make your move build
build build try to lower your dca that's
all there is to do but because when you
enter a game like stocks real estate or
anything it's like you don't go for one
bag and leave you're like in it until
you die exactly like that's the game
that's the game and this is what i tell
myself because i lost a million twice so
yeah
it's just you know 735 000 the first
time million to the second time however
i did cash out like quite a bit which
feels good i cashed out um
but not as much as i put in yeah see
that's the trick why do we keep talking
about this i didn't cash out anything
but we keep [ __ ] talking about to
punish if we could just go back to like
well no because if you remember anthony
if you remember you said you wanted to
hold luna for years and years yeah i did
and i told you i was like i'm very
scared what's going on with putin and
then he's going back to the moon right
no i said i'm cashing out see
that's what i said stop putting these
words in my mouth no and then you said
you said look at me remember and i quote
that's like five out of ten what do i
know i'm
what
[ __ ]
dancer
i'm gonna pop and lock my way out of
this one
i heard him say that that's what he said
was weird i was like that's an awkward
thing this is a weird reference why
would you do that yeah
hey biden is your president biden is the
[ __ ] president yeah watch your
[ __ ] mouth he is the president no
more of this let's go brandon stuff oh
do you question that no it's it's the
truth he is the president
not my president oh no what does that
mean who's your president
controversy on jk
he's [ __ ] my president bud
my president is good ol eisenhower oh
yeah
i was not a good choice yes sir
because he told us about the military
industrial complex
in a speech and you say we gotta watch
out for that but he's a conspiracy
theorist and he also interned a lot of
japanese people i think so i'm not
really i was kind of based yeah yeah
kind of time
that's what everyone says right let's
review i know who my
eleanor the the moose hunter yep he's a
gangster dude rapper would just like
he would set up a boxing ring at the
white house and just box people for fun
he also got shot yeah he finished his
speech he was a crazy military captain
right but the other roosevelt is the
[ __ ]
the polio man
yeah last time i checked the white house
has some stairs
a lot teddy roosevelt would have polio
[ __ ] still get up
recover from polio because polio can't
live in him
but you know what he did he rolled down
the stairs he's a very he was a very
big man that he was
wait no sorry taft was only made the
[ __ ] tub bigger you got stuck right
is that the legend i'm surprised
everybody knows so much about the
roosevelts no it's just because we we we
click on those things that have like 52
images and then we keep on reading the
one side
the cracked little fun fun bits yeah you
won't believe what happened to this
president number two image 20. oh no
where is it it's not here
okay once you get to 51 you're like i
don't think this fact is in here at all
no so this cat he um
he's putting a down payment on his
future now uh his family is very
skeptical obviously
entropia calls itself the world's
longest running metaverse it launched in
2003. but this is how friday 2003 yeah
this is that's why he's been playing the
game for years and then he cashed out
five g's
what the [ __ ] is this game what do you
play how do you play this game you can
play it right now you just farm and
trophy you're playing for yours cash out
five g's i i've never played it i love
it this [ __ ] is older than [ __ ]
facebook instagram all that [ __ ] bro
what games can you even think of that
are still running from 2003. oh this
should i mean that's still not around
they they should be
right it looks like nerd [ __ ]
it looks pretty nerdy huh yeah dude you
know the graphics are dope yeah the
graphics are sick about this i don't
know about this picture wait it's unreal
engine [ __ ] look at the current [ __ ]
don't look at the old french
this one's not bad that's like looking
at half-life one and you're like oh
helpless [ __ ] looks like [ __ ]
he's like wolfenstein won
what the [ __ ] is this dude he's like
yeah doom looks like a [ __ ] actually i'm
still [ __ ] like
doing like sick
you guys remember how you had to buy
doom in order to install counter strike
on your computer and then i never played
doom before but i had to go through the
whole campaign because i couldn't get
counter-strike hey have you seen all the
memes out there about what can run doom
yeah
texas instruments do you see the uh
mcdonald's instruments
do you see it running out of birth
control
no dude that's great a pregnancy test
it's wild that's amazing like real real
i've seen it running on a mcdonald's
kiosk
sideways yeah sideways whatever wait why
because the cpu like [ __ ] yeah it's
weird all requirements are just so
minimal that you can run on anything
you're running on a [ __ ] tamagotchi
now tamagotchi yeah if you wanted to
what was your what was your favorite old
school pc game of that era like team
fortress classic
team fortress but you like the pirate
game yeah no parking is now old-school
pc [ __ ] like like work world of war i
mean not world of warcraft just warcraft
one [ __ ] command and conquer
starcraft starcraft uh
yeah like what was i was in a clan
called dark oman
for team fortress classic yeah we were
sick damn son girls wanted to have sex
with us
all of them all every single one of them
um because well they all said they all
said they were girls never got around to
it because they were playing
they all claimed they were women because
we were online but yeah did you guys
ever go to computer cafes to play
counter-strike no pc bang it was always
either starcraft or counter-strike
always oh they had they had this um
this place where you could check your
ranking
based on your kill death ratio and [ __ ]
and at one point i was i'm not kidding
13th in the world
at team fortress classic
yeah guess ask me how much sex i was
having how much like oodles i hadn't had
sex yet
i bet you right now you probably get so
much actual puss
so much i think you're right if you
expect if you're 13th in the world
esports dude esports is yeah you saw
that coming didn't we [ __ ] riding you
while you're playing [ __ ] there was
this fortnight [ __ ] hugh jackman
swordfish you remember when we all had
nintendo cartridges we're all blowing on
it and everyone talks about that now
because of like we didn't talk to each
other but we all need to do that
there was this method at the time in
this game team fortress classic where if
you used a concussion grenade you could
jump
like all over the [ __ ] map like
rocket jumping but like nobody taught me
how to do that i like figured out how to
[ __ ] do that on my own and so like
everyone on my team was like yo snake is
kind of a [ __ ] legend
yeah that was my name in the game
snake snake it's not ace it wasn't as
that was my pool hole not iceman no
iceman came later no you were steve
snake bro i got the captain cool was
recent okay but snake everyone's like yo
snake is [ __ ] good at this [ __ ] so
one time i was playing i was playing
this game i was on offense there's
offense and defense in team forces
classes because you have to protect your
friends offensive defense in general i
was the the offensive coordinator of my
[ __ ] team all right that's how much
sex i was having
all right so the version of the time
yeah yeah so my my team um we were
behind by two caps which is like you
have to capture the flag twice too it's
a big deal to win right
so
um
my team was supposed to be going in and
clearing the room because they had
[ __ ] ngs who are setting up these
[ __ ] turret guns
and i can't concussion grenade through
there with the flag and get the [ __ ] out
if you guys aren't blowing the room up
before i get in there
so eventually my team was just being
such incompetent [ __ ] morons frankly
my demo man's like [ __ ] up so hard i
was like i actually was because we're
all uncomfortable on like this this like
chat thing at the time and i was like
all right [ __ ] you guys i want to just
do it myself and i actually just dropped
my headset on the ground and snake
he went rogue
probably when i peaked
i was sexually
this this is your flu game this is like
my greatest moment in sports history mj
fluge this is your flu yeah my flu game
so like
i immediately can crush your grenade
over to the enemy and whatever to fort
i get i i like i like bunny hop all the
way in i the the the um the sentry guns
barely even register i'm in the room
already had the flag i'm gone i'm
concussion grenading out i'm bunny
hopping all the way up the spiral
staircase i bunny hop all the way out i
can question it all the way and then i
pick up my headset
after i cap it i go that's one and i
drop it on the ground
i did the same [ __ ] thing
and i'm not kidding as soon as i grab
the flag the second time doing the same
[ __ ] thing they're all trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] was just going
on because like i was a shadow
[Laughter]
i capped the set i grabbed the second
one i i capped it and i'm not kidding i
by the time i pick up my headset the map
ends and like so we just won that match
and my whole clan is on the coms thing
just screaming
holy [ __ ] snake holy [ __ ]
and that was when i peeked for 30 years
why did you take it off because i didn't
get in the zone
wow did you pass out afterwards yeah
that's all i had that was all the energy
i had
all the blood rushing in the massive
boater that you had mom the spaghetti
now
i woke up and i looked like i was 21 and
i was 13 still
i put it all in there oh god all in the
game baby congrats man that's a big deal
snake
[Music]
you